[Music]
Rollie brows fireteam I guess
quick just do what you want to do
welcome to the worst fire team ever well
Erik Griffin Erich Koch Frank Castillo
are you so nasally man this is why you
sure this money though and I bring it up
all time whenever he he imitates
somebody else ain't goes is this place
yeah but it's more of his voice I gotta
get roided-up then I can sound like coke
you know we don't we don't discuss it in
public anyway alright so anyways here's
our Werth fireteam we haven't done this
in a long time sitting around on a round
table and just talk about games and the
things that we've been doing and I
thought we should we could do a fun
recap of just everything that has
happened you know with the with the the
fireteam and yes hold on and also
Pikachu's kind of one of our newer
members
that's Pikachu everybody everybody ever
want to know what he looked like yeah
yeah is if you can't see don't let this
point him out but don't let this tool
fool you he's really little he's
actually standing on the stool bank
brent lovell comb so you know what's
funny is i think back to when we started
like how this really really started was
it was me and bobby lee playing video
games just him and i'm playing late at
night late at night and then he got his
brother in and then it was the three of
us playing and then Steve got he was at
my neighbor play and then you you got in
and then one night Frank and I were just
playing and then we randomly started
playing with this guy or the coke here
just like randomly just talking and
playing and then finding out off the
board yeah yeah yeah just like like
Rando play Rando gameplay and and then
here we are then we like you know form
this thing and then it's it's it's had
many different evolutions and yes this
is the current one
[Laughter]
for them for the moment it reminds me of
like what like playing video games was
first like you know when you first play
video games like you start playing with
guys that you've never met before and
then you eventually meet and that I
think that's a lot of fun too this is
the fact that we've all you know
especially with you we've all become
really good friends off of just [ __ ]
shooting aliens oh that's what I think's
unique I was uh I think I was talking to
Lindsay about an article saying that
there was a mental illness with being
addicted to video games and I was like
you know anything in in excess is bad
but at the same time I've met a lot of
cool people just just be plain we we met
Gavin aider who's somebody I've been
playing with live in four years you know
and I've never met the dude in person
never even seen him that's why it's
weird cuz like we have that connection
we've known each other for so long but
we're like in the store like is that gap
you know it's crazy the voice you hear
the person's voice oh you were totally
not what I imagined your weight fatter
than I thought you know what's funny
about that I saw an article about a guy
who's the best man he was the best man
of a dudes wedding and it was like he
that's the first time they met yeah yeah
a wedding you know but I mean I think
everything comes with moderation you
know I was like we keep you know we keep
losing people because of like
relationships you're in a relationship
I'm in a relationship so I haven't
played necessarily as much but I still
find a balance that's why you need your
you're about to get married
oh yeah it's a tough balance but you'll
find a new balance but it's also so hard
to be like yo can you move to the
bedroom so I could play video games in
the living room and talk to all my
friends and she's just like no go [ __ ]
yourself yeah I mean like it's like so
you gotta figure it out you know what it
is what it is and I had this talk with
Lindsay she goes I just wish you laughed
as much as you laughed when you're on
with that well I go so so I'm not
supposed to have a good time when I'm
when I'm doing that yeah and I'm like
I'm like okay and you know like I'm
playing with comedians right like this
is their jobs like naturally they're
just funny no but you just I'm sure that
she feels like when you're with her that
nothing she could do that you will have
the same kind of emotional response that
you have when you're playing but that's
what they just can't stand us doing
something that's so fun that doesn't
involve them they try they want like so
like Rachel like and and that when it
was first started she like let me play
let me try this she gets to controller
and then you know she can't keep her HUD
you know she just gets so frustrated
with it this she's just like I can't be
involved in this and so that's what it
really becomes involved in this thing
that you love so much
well I love video games more than I love
my fiancee
so is this yeah that was Frank yes so
but but here we are playing in like so
if we think about the game destiny you
know we've been playing destiny now for
four years is that right as if I mean
I've never played a game as long and it
continuously like you know even if you
think about like I have FIFA I've been
playing fifa for more than longer than
that but I had to buy a new feature
every year right like it's like this one
there's just very little improvements
you know it's just and then they and
then they're they're fooling us because
they're just be like oh we're gonna
bring back a gun from two years ago like
it that that's new like it's crazy kind
of cuz he knows the only game that I
played and like religiously as much as
the same company I know exactly and
that's why yeah like I because I try to
think of it too
like when we get on and we're not doing
anything aimlessly playing and Griffin
site why are we playing this yeah yeah
you know ever do what you're going your
fifth strike like this you just like
you're not even getting any rewards it's
a hundred percent on the challenges
already but you just you know just
talking or whatever you just say why am
i I've done this strike so many times
you know I think we have a problem no
well I was thinking about it and I
honestly think it just comes down to how
smooth that game is just as much as as
much as the game plays great like the
gun play and the game play I mean that's
what keeps me coming back because
there's no other game with that response
yeah the mechanics yeah yeah every bump
up G and it's terrible but it's fun but
not Destiny's game place keeps bringing
you busy and I let I like pop G but if
it was like the level it is on PC mm-hmm
I'd be all for absolutely I just had
this use with the rendering yeah and I
would I would hope I keep saying I wish
to destiny they might they might realize
how we better come up with some kind of
battle royale version of our game
because that's where everybody's going
right you know because if they did oh my
god yeah they no one can compete new
Call of Duty and it's mostly multiplayer
there's no single there's trip what
their yeah they're doing the multiplayer
is gonna stay the way it is so far the
competitive Call of Duty players
it'll be like team deathmatch oh yeah
but the single-player will be a battle
royale mode everybody there's no
campaign that was the thing I was always
a big fan of the campaign I love a good
support but you can't paint though the
campaign it comes and goes yeah I play
it's not something you could keep
replaying I mean it's like but you know
even with destiny they found a way that
you know we keep doing these same things
like how many times have we done you
just like like I said like a strikes or
like you know so like that's if they
were gonna do anything that's what they
would do they would find a way they well
you have to do the campaign again so you
can get this gun or do the campaign
that's the only way I mean it's just
like with a what's that other game we
like division division yeah they just
sent them an email blast which is what I
think division I think is the only
company I think is actually kind of done
it right where it's like they would [ __ ]
stuff up and then they or they realize
certain weapons were overpowered and
then they'd like you know constantly amp
it up division is to say isn't it the
same as call the duty company isn't not
yet Ubisoft is a different oh it's not
okay yeah but call it duties Activision
yes off does well I think I'll then Ruby
stop that's the same one to do Batman
right no that's Warner Brothers and
that's Rocksteady rotten they just sent
out a real blast of from division saying
that it's like if you because they're
new games about to come out division -
yeah and they're like if you want to
start playing again they'll give you all
the highest armor right now at the
current game setting so you could play
until the new game real
what are you guys excited for cuz I mean
I'm super excited for cyberpunk 2077
like they showed that at e3 and you guys
haven't seen that oh you got a spot
trailer for that it's sick but like
what's the premise of it like what is
it's like it's like an art like kind of
like a future had you like the future
yeah yeah and then like steampunk events
do you know not stink like cyberpunk
whatever but the idea is like it's it's
like you lost my mind it's kind of its
kind of like a cyberpunk version of The
Witcher it's made by the same group so
like it's like you're in the future but
you just got to see it it's very like no
if I can get involved in another game
say that I can't but you're gonna play
Division 2 I I don't know yet I haven't
decided if I'm gonna buy division I
think if you all bought division to do
not be liked it might get a good play
yeah there's like five games of playing
right now state of the K to 12 G
fortnight and destiny and then also I
Reebok Red Dead Redemption
yeah the new ones coming anyone's coming
out is that Red Dead Redemption as
rockstar
that's the shooting Wes account Western
oh yeah like GTA in the what I could you
say something good look at his face is
like yeah something he doesn't know that
first podcast
all right let's look at quiet and just a
lot of them have five bits okay good I
use five minutes as excited for Fallout
76 actually yeah yeah that's why that's
why he's the crush so cool I noticed
that you're a fighter
well the only reason why I'm will play
fallout is because Bobby said he'll play
he'll play and we can do multi you get
fallout and I was like I just don't like
loner games but apparently it's going on
yeah it's gonna be insane I'm actually
gonna but like that what I'm curious to
see what the multi player actually is Oh
from what what's the word can't from
what engine you can't destroy each other
or their bases or anything you can you
can do missions to get a new car a new
color PC missions - yeah that might be
cool but you do as a team it's like a
team or new cabal little North Korea's
Bobby's getting his team ready
but yeah that'll be cool I think that'll
follow be cool I'm excited for
multiplayer fallout well that's what I
mean like game we should decide because
there is a huge division online presence
right a lot of people play division and
yes in the same amount of people I think
that play destiny it's the same kind of
thing and they're a and they just they
don't stop they've been they've been
addicted this holds well you know
Ubisoft really good at like their first
game was always kind of okay and then
they do really well usually with their
second or third softer be soft okay I
couldn't tell if he was like [ __ ]
with us no but no the reason I'm saying
is because like hopefully Division two
will take what Division One didn't make
it even more but here's the thing I was
playing Division I don't know you have
you gone on it recently yeah you know
they they they add it like a crucible oh
really yeah Wow they added like a
four-on-four you know with the with
those guns and all that stuff right but
the problem is when you play destiny and
then you go to that you can't it's a
whole different kind of yeah I can't
move the same it's not a smooth year it
doesn't have the reaction time so I hope
that they improve that mm-hmm right so I
don't I don't know I mean I mean that's
what I'm seeing like I would like again
I really wish destiny would come up with
a 40 on 40 or you know what
Battlefront well dozen great Battle
Royale
what's that new mode that's coming out
so they have an update coming the
forsaken podcast gambit gambit it's like
it's like PvE and PvP mix together so
like they match you PvP they match you
with another group and you gotta fight a
bunch of like you know just random
monsters right now taking fall then one
of your guys right how does that work
well so like when you kill these enemies
you pick these motes up and you put them
in this thing that collects all the
motes and then once you hit like kind of
like killstreaks and call duty when you
hit certain light levels like 25 minutes
off then you can like send one of your
guys in to the opponent's arena to kill
them while they're trying to kill all
these so like it's it's all like you
start [ __ ] people [ __ ] and that's I
mean Isis and the portion that we lost
people on the pocket yeah people were
just like what this is about this is
where they're gone one person goes to
another team and messes with them when
they're trying to do this thing and
there's there's another one where like
you get enough you get to send like a
really hard boss a really hard boss in
there that's you know I mean I'm
surprised destiny isn't gonna go like
battle royale style because like I'm
sure the only the only thing that I
would just be hesitant about because
battle royale right now I think is kind
of like a fatty oh yeah
it starts dying down then you're gonna
see but see I don't know if it's gonna
die down because of the fact that so
many people can be involved at a
particular time and I think that's the
thing that is still gonna be appealing
for a long time I agree and I can see
people that stick with it my only issue
with it is you know if I'm playing
destiny I can play you know a quick
crucible match and then I can just kind
of keep it going I can die respawn down
on what sucks about games like that is
you invest a lot of time into one match
mm-hmm and then a little more a lot of
times most times you're not gonna win
because there's how many people hunted
being the last person is it's great and
that's why you can't that's why it feels
good it feels gonna win but at the same
time I hate investing like two hours and
playing three four games and like I lose
that's just the way I just hate losing
in general is the saltiest dude I mean
words teammate one day as your second
birthday but he's the word let me tell
you he was so salty he he there was like
two days in a row where he was doing
terrible and he just quit I can't do
this I gotta go
and he just his missions are so spot on
but I can't do it coax is weird like you
know what the voice you're doing now is
closer to code but my problem since
Craig's trying to call me out my problem
is it's one of the worst destiny players
I've ever seen and when he gets when he
gets on and he wants to [ __ ] play
trials which is like the most you know
what it's not that he's bad at the game
he's a bad teammate he don't he's
control freak and he's just like you
know we should go outside we're like you
know what the one I hate is announced
I'd missed that one math wheeze like we
gotta go to rugs let's go to rugs we
every time we go to rugs we die and
there's like okay well I'm just gonna go
you know that's why we lose and he says
you don't listen no I don't want to do
something and he'll try it like you said
I'll try to like tell us what to do yeah
and he's like well I'm doing better
outside but then I'm like you're one of
the worst players so why are we catering
to where your batter is I'm doing better
hats yeah you know what I'm saying but
like I need some better together but
this guy let me tell you what this guy
does if we lose it all not a good leader
here's what I saw me it wants to be
alone he wants to be a sniper and like
you know just by himself I gotta be the
closest [ __ ] to India but you
have to like learn how to lead the team
you know to me oh man this is gonna hate
it I mean he's yelling
you know what for our fans that already
watch our gameplay like I don't even
have to [ __ ] say anything here we all
right we got people from you know what
though you know what though you know you
have to be a good teammate alright
yeah I'm gonna ask the ball Kobe you
have to pass the ball what could I do
better
what grip from your your point of view
what could I do better than from one
from a coach not still want to do from
what coach is pointing to what you speak
to us while we're playing communications
like that doesn't help okay we shut down
okay okay but but what I'm when I'm
going like I'm telling us how bad we are
is not helpful either
well you just that's not love you just
got to work let's give him some tough
love about you being bad for me it's you
it's you just being salty because this
dude gets salty real quick you look at
one game this is my issues whole this
personality this reversion and then like
this is my issue though I'm going back
to like when when Craig wants to do
trials trials is super competitive we
almost never look look if we've we've
what taken you flawless we've had cards
will you do good never been flawless on
with it so Craig Craig is a complete
lost cause but what pisses me off and
when we try to do [ __ ] like this and
Craig wants to talk about Donald Trump
or Craig Craig Craig always brings up
some [ __ ] but the biggest I get it cuz I
listen because you got a phone listen to
him and arrow and those guys play trials
and it's just like it's too much right I
mean coming your way and is I'm very
much like yeah or salty but they get
even salty salty I he got saltier arrow
once they get they get salty a teacher
you should change whether the
the group - from - from 2029 - a soft
salty salt the salt shakers just with
m4z Frank because you know I'm a very
busy man carrying other headliners
luggage gonna make my $300 somehow
that's why you got to get one of those
Vanguard game things yeah actually I
really want to add the whole time I was
like everywhere this whole trip every
day we like drone were just chillin in
hotels and there just be hours and I'm
just like I've got nothing to do and I'm
like gotta brush up my [ __ ] ex yeah
so especially if you have a new one you
have to have if you have a xbox 1s or X
that man it's awesome fits right if
anyone wants to you know I do recommend
getting one of those yeah those are
gretna new and they want to actually
make some some worse fart team ever raps
oh yeah sell them stuff like that yeah
they want them so if you want to wrap
your controller and like a worst fire
team logo right yeah that kind of stuff
so sure rappin that study comin soon
people that are listening to us that'd
be hilarious have a Griffin's face on a
controller yeah why not yeah yeah no
there's none wrong I'm saying
tossing ideas for merch how you doing
over there Pikachu I'm doing great
anyways to get back on track so if they
do come out with like he's you think
that the battery off fats gonna go away
and I think that that's something that's
not gonna go away I think all games are
gonna move towards this and I give an
example of something I play NBA Live
mm-hmm you know you know EA and ba live
and so you have the you could play the
seasons and all that crap but the thing
that I find myself going towards more is
they have a three on three and a five on
five with other players right so you end
up playing three on three with like you
know six people are playing and pickup
game in a pickup game and they have this
thing where you know you get prizes and
points where you can get different shoes
and different clothes and different like
and that's what the games are turning
into this sort of reward system right
while you're playing with other people
as opposed to like playing like you know
the the these the missions in the story
you're getting like cosmetics and so
with fortnight I never I just started
kind of really getting into it where
it's like after you start winning stuff
you start getting tears and you get like
cosmetics and then it's like those are
just yours to keep and it doesn't affect
the game but it's like oh this is kind
of nice it's like me personalized oh my
character murdered thing that we think
this stuff is cool I mean I was never
into the shaders and stuff with destiny
and at first you know Bobby that was so
into the I love how it looks but then
now that I've been playing so long and I
need something to do it's like oh yeah
let me change you know all my shaders
into you know all my like when you look
at it you go you know so I think that
that's something that like that's
something I like about division by the
way it's like the customization of your
armor and of the guns I think in
division it's the best I do want to
bring up I did getting you into that
game did you yeah cuz I was like yeah we
should play division you're like I can't
get into another game and then you
started playing it and then I actually
quit cuz I didn't like it and then you
kept playing the difference between
though division and destiny is that you
will get sick of division yeah there's a
mama where you're just like I can't play
it cuz the missions are so long yeah
like when you do those incursions yeah
oh my god cuz they're really hard they
have like different tiered levels of
doing it and that's how you get the
maximum amount of armor it'd be like you
know it's like doing a raid right right
you know but and by the way I've watched
this up numerous times and I gotta keep
bringing it up until destiny until
Bungie figure this [ __ ] out
you can't force us to play with six
people and so now I gotta find six
destiny players array to play this rate
and then every other part of the game I
can't play with these six people right
yeah that's ridiculous
so now we have a core group of people
and now like okay let's go patrol and we
can't patrol together we can't do we
can't do anything together so I think
that the the in the future they really
got to make it so every part of the game
you could play with you know people I
think there should be a six person
strike
like I think it should just be like like
if you have two people in the strike so
that they just tear it out you know like
it's not as hard right right so you
should be you could do it by yourself
and you happen anything if two people
give you choice more choice period I
mean like I hate what crucible I can't
choose yeah we all know you don't my
stuff no but I mean that's not from
definitely one yeah I was just so random
or no destiny - I raged on Craig one
time one there must have been about
supremacy it was hundred percent because
or because Craig acts as if he plays
supremacy worse than he plays any other
mode which isn't the case like supremacy
wait wait let me let me let me ask some
questions among his beef okay okay come
knowing you guys as well as I know you
guys now one he probably wasn't picking
up any of the things he never he does he
never does it for anybody I'm just gonna
stop right there I'm gonna break some
[ __ ] down I'm gonna break supremacy so
supremacy when you get a kill you get a
point you get another point if you pick
up their crest so Craig's Craig's
ideology is I'm gonna just I'm not gonna
try and kill anybody
I'm just gonna go run and pick up these
fellows which that happens if somebody
kills Craig they get a point if nobody's
around Craig cuz Craig's running around
trying to pick up kress
they pick up his crest that's two points
he just gave the enemy team two points
okay if I'm back and even if I'm killing
not picking up crest I'm getting point
point point point point he goes KD
doesn't matter it's about picking up the
crest that KD does matter and not only
that I know I hate he finished I do I do
Tyson came I do pick up crest if it
doesn't one it doesn't risk me dying and
the the reward is bigger than the risk
so like if like so this is pursuing me
no no it doesn't pick up crap no no no
no just what he said the point of the
game
no-no-no anybody that watches our
podcast watch our gameplay we got
[ __ ] footage of it I definitely I get
more points and I pick up more cress
than you do because I survive if only we
could go to more often Ron James talked
to his teammates like make all the
baskets watch our game no you don't make
it like this all the time New York's
don't weigh too much and Pikachu's a
benchwarmer I gotta bring them in yeah
he really is but hopefully I still think
that every time I think I'm done with
destiny every time I think I'm out they
pull me back in you know I'm a DLC they
just out of bounties it's coming
tomorrow
Wow knees yeah oh yeah knees are coming
tomorrow my heart huh wait what was what
was that before where you go to the guy
and you get the little robot oh yeah oh
man oh no both are crucible and first
put that but see that would make okay so
I think that the challenge is weren't
enough is what it is mm-hmm because
that's what bounties are as tough
challenges right right right yeah well
now what now you get the whole oh god
now I think that's what destiny you
should been all your time like the
dismantling [ __ ] yeah yeah know what I'm
trying to do in tubes like I'm tired of
going to the gunsmith like the other day
I had a thousand yeah things cuz I just
hadn't been doing it I'm just cuz they
because it fills up your thing then you
got to go over to the freakin pulse
matter and the promise they give you too
much and too much of the same yes yes so
it's like the same so it's like it's a
you get the same guns over and over
animals coming in that you know what I
think is needed I hear something I was a
little playing last night and I was
looking at like sorry I would you don't
play with titans no but there's
something about the titan armor though
this is a like the titan armor this is
what i like about this is like now i got
it this is something on lock of my
destiny
so the titan armor it lends itself
towards resilience yeah I can get your
resilience up to ten mm-hmm okay I don't
like that that you can't do that with a
hunter you know cuz what you mean like
ten resilience yeah no because because
the way the armor is set up like for
hunters it's all about speed recovery
and recovery so they don't even let you
decide well I want a strong hunter I
don't want my hundred to be as fast I
want them to be strong and they've set
the tempo with that with like how they
would with with the armor I like a
certain play style yeah yeah well it
should be more customizable I think
they'll be dope yeah well nothing I miss
is the from destiny one is the trees oh
yeah yeah yeah like being able to like
pick ability and really awesome eyes I
like that more but I will say because I
said it from the beginning at destiny -
I was worried about the fixed roles
because what had me playing anything
besides crucible like doing strikes was
looking for that god roll yeah you know
what I'm saying
so like that gave me a lot of reality so
like now I remember Franken is grasping
Malik yeah you were the best back then
it was a short time yeah until I showed
up yeah no but they have I know she's a
go but but ya know having random roles
and now that I think they're doing
something with the mod system to where
you get to add another we uh Frank back
up a little bit there you go right there
so we can get Craig in today right there
Craig come forward I'm looking forward
to the new the new DLC le but these
little things that we're talking about
are things I wish they were it would
make it it's like already such a great
game even with these things we don't
like we still yeah well you still play
but I think that they need like because
here's another thing - like if I'm going
to
if I'm going to like you know the earth
and I'm gonna and I'll go to that guy in
with the sniper or whatever his name is
devran kay Darren I don't want to get a
gun from him that I could get anywhere
else
yeah like I don't like that either it's
like I'm like when you go to like
mercury or Mars now and you go to that
you know you go to the lady and then you
get that gun that you could get anywhere
it's the same gun about reskin yeah it's
like it's all the same stuff so I wish
they would like you know and more
personalized personalization yeah you
guys look forward to any other stuff
coming out division - I'm just not into
a lot of games so I'm into sports games
division
I mean sports games in destiny those are
the top two for me so I played a lot of
FIFA that's especially with the World
Cup going on yeah just World Cup
tournament going on like you could just
keep going in a tournament every time
you go on and I like you know like I
said like destiny I like obviously I
like destiny but I will I haven't bought
a call duty well I said I wasn't gonna
buy any more Call of Duty titles last
four I've hated right but it's - you
know what how do I not to cut you off
just call of duty I never got into
college because I thought it was just is
too childish to like the game play the
polenta game played the PD apology I
just got tired or like the racism and
tired of that because like if I go back
to like Gears of War the first Gears of
War it was four on it was four people
and then your and that you end up
talking to those four people I remember
when they went to six then it got crazy
it got like where's too many people
talking and then Call of Duty was always
like that where I was like I'm out I'm
out this is a fun yeah because the fun
of it is like when you kind of know
people and in this and then you know but
anyways go on so you like Call of Duty
but no you thinking about getting this
new one with the battery won't wait I'm
not gonna pre-order it because i
pre-ordered the other ones and I was
just I hate disappointed but um I'm
gonna I'm gonna wait a couple days cuz
what the new battle royale mode called
Duty can make smooth games and they got
it there they're a big they're a big
company they got a lot of money funding
where where pubsey I think is dropping
it is they just they put it out there
for council players but they're really
you know they care they own it
they're catering to PC so like with
rendering and all that [ __ ] like right
they don't care so let's call a duty if
they come out with a smooth Battle
Royale I know the weird is I hate for it
but I will let's talk about fortnight I
hate fortnight and I'll tell you why I
hate for it oh here we go
building yeah tough it's so like you
know what she was starting to get into
it actually when you watch the kids or
plan have another young friend of mine
he play it played with him and he's you
know he's building the Taj Mahal like
that's nothing cuz I like I love
shooters oh but like I'm not a minecraft
player yeah and that's what I feel like
100% yeah I was in when I was in South
Carolina I met I was talking with a guy
that was running the show and he was
like yeah we have one of the best
fortnight players in the country that
lives in this town I was like what do
you mean he's like yeah he's 14 he's top
5 and I was like are you kidding me he's
like yeah and then he was telling me
about how like at their venue they're
gonna start doing like video game shows
and stuff and he was like I could sell
that [ __ ] out here and he was just
amazed that people come to that
yeah but the guy's dad was like I was
concerned because my kid was playing
video games so much and then he found
out how much money he could make and
then he was now he's all about his kid
yeah I'm with you on fortnight I can't
stand building like I mean I still like
it though I mean I play with air on them
and they're good but I gotta be honest I
just let them build and not just what
you're talking about right now something
that I have a problem with all those
type of games and even with destiny is I
need I need at least with destiny when
I'm not I don't know how they do the
ranking but like when I'm not playing
with you yeah I got 25 kills and I'm
half so at least I know that they have
some kind of like balance there's like a
balancing out where you're playing with
other players but like fortnight in the
pub G it's like I'm never gonna win that
game well you know you know it's like I
only play because I'm playing we're
playing with my friends laughing a good
time yeah but like so I think that
what's wrong with some of those games
it's like there's no middle ground you
either have to be a gamer right you need
to be 14 and like me the top 5 or you're
just like Annis isn't fun yeah there's
no middle ground for those people and I
think that it also
depends on your team load - because I
mean I was I playing with arrow we went
we won fortnight like what do you call
when you win the game the round the
victory yeah I was doing a dinner from
pub G all right but we actually won one
and it was because they were they were
good and they you know they were
throwing up buildings and they were good
at leading you know arrows good at
leading that's a pretty good name you
don't even hear me let me just say I
agree to disagree there's different ways
that can here we go but but I mean so
depends on your team go to win and they
were really good and they kind of helped
but I mean I was fine shooting they were
better at building and that's that that
helps if you have a team in fortnight
because definitely I suck at building I
mean the building is just boring it's
not but if that games there's free
people is its switch creations rank was
playing on yes I'm so raising that new
Drake album though by the way do you
like it why really yeah it's good it's a
really good album but I mean I like I
want to hate him I'm so tired of him oh
yeah
no but I was like okay enough of this
guy
right i I was listening on the way here
I like that album is what's your
favorite song Griffin scorpion is that I
have I don't know the names in my
feelings that's a good one you know I'll
obey the guy I like my food truck is
great how like I was his other albums
real good too yeah Sam wasn't I didn't
like the other oh yeah but he's on
everybody's track I'm surprised he's not
on our fire team you know I mean it's
like you're dragging it you get Drake or
you get the rock and I mean they're
everywhere I have a great Drake store if
you want to tell it real quick alright
alright cool so
you I love this so the store you know
all the famous celebrities come well
Drake came to the rose petal ones and he
ended up not being able to make it
because he got stopped and someone
dragged him into the main room because
it was one of the shows there anyways so
I go to walk up to ask him to come up to
the Rose battle cuz he was gonna judge
and as I go in there's a comic on stage
who doesn't know Drake's there and he
has a whole like five minute bit of him
just [ __ ] on Drake was amazing
because it was like he's up he's not the
best comic in the world anyways he was a
younger guy you know I mean there's like
no miker and he it was like his spot on
this show like he forgot how about on
the show great would it be if I'd rate
does a rap about that open mind yeah but
he went up and he did a little bit and
it was so [ __ ] funny cuz everyone was
laughing but they weren't laughing
because he was funny they were laughing
because they all knew Drake was here
when he didn't and like so he was like
oh [ __ ] so he like keeps going the only
just talking [ __ ] and seven just keeps
going to his material everyone went up
to over shook his hand afterwards so
afterward like yeah afterwards he comes
out in the leaves and then someone tells
him the Drake's there and he's like oh
[ __ ] so he tries to go up and like shake
Drake's handbag yo man you know just
play then Drake just gives them the cold
shoulder and for everybody and no one
saw my kid again never to be seen again
speak in a comedy wasn't there some beef
between you two and so we're having to
go up on stage and there's eight of us
playing destiny okay arrow in the guy
huh huh Gavin was Gavin playing I was a
bunch of guys playing alright it's like
our core this guy is always mister you
could beat us like he well I got you he
goes he goes he wants to challenge two
on six he wants to go to on six
sexify Carolina arrow
versus six of us right yeah so we're
like okay and then he's armed too he's
talking to beat you guys you know how he
is talking mad [ __ ] so of course he's
they're not winning so in a minute that
moment they're not winning then he goes
in you guys should be cleaning this
anyway there's six with you guys and
it's like I got mad because it's like
there's no way to you can't win in that
situation if we lose right he talked
about it if we win I don't need the
defense I won't anyway so I'm getting he
won't even let this point come out he's
talking [ __ ] he's like well you're
terrible at this game
[Laughter]
you missed with that Griffin you miss
Griffin what are you doing way down
there you're the only person that went
negative
you didn't even you didn't even get a
thousand
like you can't follow me on stage let me
just let me tell you cause like it's
rare to get Griffin to red zone do you
remember when we were playing with Bobby
and you Eric snapped on him and like
even Bobby like what silence day I
forget what it was but Steve was dying
yeah steve was dying cuz he knew like
Bobby was legit afraid cuz Griffin's
like I'll [ __ ] you know I'll [ __ ] you up
like yeah you never hear that from
that's what it reminded me of it's like
what you want to meet me at the Comedy
Store
I want to see that battle off though I
want to see him do a five-minute set at
The Comedy Store I would pay a million
that's why we play destiny
yeah but but to defend myself because I
said the defense was coming the defense
is coming
the defense was coming Griffin makes it
seem like he doesn't antagonize we're
doing two verses
look the people doing all the work is
arrow and killing they're doing all the
work and they're not saying a damn word
you got Griffon following them around
like you know why you know all this guy
this way every kill I got on him is
gratifying it's a win you get one kill
on ko no no but the problem is you were
the one with the build up you were the
one talking [ __ ] going into the six on
two so I was just giving it back to you
I like challenges not only that not only
that when we were gonna do it before we
owe me was not on your team oh he joined
and he ended up leading a goddamn team
having killing we know our strengths
hey we played a game after that in which
we won it was to verse 5 I said I sided
with Griffin anyway going back to it we
got to start to wrap up yeah dates about
that but we are what we are gonna be
doing coming up is we're gonna actually
we got a we're gonna schedule match
we're Grenadier Jake you know Koch has
put out the challenge and we're gonna do
a one-on-one so that's coming soon so
look out for that and obviously we're
gonna and we're gonna stream earlier now
on Sundays not 9 o'clock 9 o'clock
eastern time now so 6 like around 6 6 7
issues when we're gonna start streaming
on Sundays and you know if you if you
want to play with us you should send us
messages and you never know you can get
in yes what's your Twitter oh yeah I'm
at Eric Griffin with a K Eric Griffin
but look for us at worst bar team let's
just promote that we're at worst fire
team we're on twitch at worst fire team
you know and then you know we're very
friendly and you know we're we've met a
lot of great people from playing destiny
with us and you know that's how I
Pikachu came in and I was here yeah I
know he's mad talkative this whole
episode I know we can't shut up
and also we're gonna have some other
things and maybe some we were talking
about the wraps and some other things
maybe coming up and I know one of our
members is not here right now so but it
is what it is we're gonna we're always
evolving we're gonna add people we're
gonna get rid of people we're gonna like
you know and we'll see what happens
[Laughter]
yeah me and Griffin you're going on tour
at the end of the year a feature film
but we all got stuff going on creo
hording you're having a fight we'll have
a fight late October early November and
hopefully get that going get out of that
healthy I want to quit turn around
because they're doing they just
announced a card in Milwaukee for
December so if I can I hit what do you I
don't want to wait for that one
not really okay like I wanna yeah I
would because I was expecting to fight
in September anyway so this is already
me in the corner I'm gonna be at be I'm
gonna be in Indiana August 5th for let's
fast so that'll be fun
and Pikachu okay anything to promote you
just check out our podcast all the
little fun a little fun bells and
whistles on our podcast that's all due
to pika jab what's this title social
media he's our social media manager
manager
thank you very social so we're the
social media social media guys quite as
fun yes yeah that's the new thing the
social media guy you doesn't mean you
just is behind a screen but anyways this
is worth fire team ever you catch us on
Twitch Instagram Twitter YouTube and
YouTube are we showing especially
YouTube thanks for the workout you want
to see the gun
Oh roast battle 3 coming out yeah thank
you guys
[Music]